christy wright ramsey personality
joins us as our co-host today here on
the dave ramsey show rebecca
is next in rebecca's in california hi
rebecca how are you
hi rebecca i mean hi rebecca oh my gosh
hi dave
hi thank you for taking my call welcome
how can we help
so i'm calling because my husband showed
up
last week from work and he says that he
wants to buy a five thousand dollar gun
we we just got out of debt um we handed
in the fleeces we purchased our our
first car cash
and we are stocking up money piling up
money to buy
a house and i am the dream killer now
because
he doesn't he thinks that you should he
should be able to buy this 5 000
gun so i just wanted to get both of your
point of view on
on this so you're out of debt you have
your emergency fund and you would have
the 5 000 beyond that but it would come
out of your
down payment fund for your house am i
understanding you're right
correct yep we have about uh 72 000
saved but we're still we live in
california so it costs a lot to buy a
house here
so that's just scratching the surface of
of buying a house we
probably need to save more along the
lines of 150
for a 20 down on a home here
okay yeah what's your household income
we make about 145 000
a year between my husband and i and is
there anything unique about this
particular purchase
i mean it's a custom gun and he's sort
of
new to the he's sort of new to it all he
has a few that he's purchased but
i mean it's just we've been like gazelle
intense for the past
year and a half and so i'm feeling a
little a little like hey let's go over
there you get to buy a five thousand
dollar gun what about my five thousand
dollar bag
you know i we we've really been we've
really really been the valentine's these
past years so it's just been kind
we're still in the middle of trying to
buy a house right well you're at the
stage that you would buy
items if you wanted to um
but it's it's it's just so fresh off the
back of the debt snowball that it feels
weird i'm sure
um so i uh uh
you know i think if you came in and said
i want to buy a 5 000
louis vuitton he might have a double
backflip
i think so i mean he well okay so i
i posed it back to him and i said well
what about you know
i'm not a bad person i i'm a bad gal i
just want to you know i
i really want a house that's really what
i want so i'm like
no you're you're setting back our goals
by you wanting to buy this gun
i mean we could probably save five
thousand dollars in two months and
cash flow the gun you have you have the
five thousand dollars now it would just
you'd put it back
in the 72 000 right we do we do
we do so that's not the issue but the
issues just matter of priorities
which one comes so here's what sharon
and i learned
we decided it's not no it's just which
one comes first
so we got an argument like this about
the time we were at the same place you
were
she was driving a god-awful nasty old
blue
astro van with 900 million miles on it
you know the two-tone blue ones
like redneck ugly you know what i'm
talking about if you're driving one out
there i'm sorry but it was redneck ugly
when we had one too
so and and it was newer back then so
she's driving that she wants to upgrade
to a suburban she's got a house full of
kids
and uh you know we're off the back end
of this bankruptcy stuff we're starting
to make some money
and i'm like you know 20 000 bucks or
whatever the stinking thing was
i can i can do a lot of work at the
office for that and i was wanting to do
some investing in stuff here
at ramsey and she's wanting to buy this
car and
um so you know we got in this big thing
about it and what we finally sat down
and figured out was
it's just a matter of when yeah and so
she got the car first
and then as soon as that was done then i
got to do the investing at the office
but it wasn't like we said
you know you can do one but can't do the
other right or there's something evil or
wrong
about buying a 5 000 gun that would be
really hypocritical on my part because i
own several
but uh the one i carry on my hip is
about that
so uh but the uh uh so i mean i i'm i'm
i'm sympathetic with him but i'm also
sympathetic with you and i will tell you
sometimes when i get a 5 000
gun it does cost me a little bit louis
vuitton occasionally but
it's a good trade-off but that's that's
way late in this baby step seven game
right
so i i think you guys just need to talk
through
you know are you're willing to wait on
other luxury purchases to get the house
this is a luxury purchase is all it is
and which
buying in and of itself is not evil
rebecca is he the spender
he is the spender he loves to spend and
i've sort of been the he was the one
with the leashes
and all the debt
it's because you have a little bit of
money and i'll tell you i'm the spender
in my marriage
and as soon as we had our emergency fund
and started to save up some money
when you have a little money if you're
the spender you're like but i got it
what's the big deal like
it's very tempting to get more careless
because you have a little bit like dave
said
this purchase is not uh evil it's not a
bad thing but i think for
him he's looking at this savings account
going well i've got the money what's the
big deal but you're looking at it from a
goals perspectives priority
i wonder if there's almost a compromise
too kind of like dave said not the
necessary bag for gun trade right now
but does it have to be nothing or a 5
000
gun or could he get excited you said
he's new to guns maybe he could get a
500
gun there's cool guns for 500 or 900
they wouldn't set you back so much that
would scratch that edge of him he's
already got some of those
um if there's a there's a i want my
words
if not if not if not then i think you
have the conversation about
like you said what comes first in
priorities because to you
you're looking at it as this is going to
set you back but he's looking at it like
hey we've got the money what's the big
deal
here's the good part of the whole
discussion hey you're discussing it
b you're going to pay cash for whatever
you do and you're going to be in
agreement
if you can continue on that pattern you
will be successful with money
regardless and so it could be that
you're saying
that you know i'd like to go on a 5 000
trip
well that would be okay and delay the
house down payment by 5 000
that would be okay too that's back when
people traveled you remember those days
and so um uh i would say cruz but we
would all laugh out loud right now
and so but as an example you know you
could spend that five thousand dollars a
lot of different ways but in any of
those cases it would be okay
but you're choosing to delay your house
by that little bit amount when you do
that
so one one last idea is
um i would either say wait until after
the house but maybe you just say
you know when we get to uh you know
we're 72 now
we need 150 is our goal when we get to x
between now and 150 maybe we stop there
and you have a splurge and he has a
splurge and then we re-engage the house
thing
or something like that uh you know maybe
maybe there's a couch that you want to
buy i don't know whatever it is
because none of those things at your
stage are out of line with what we teach
they're they're wise purchases they're
fine purchases
it's just a matter of what you want what
you said christie's exactly right what
do you want what does he want
and the good news is we talk about it
and certainly on an expensive thing like
that it's good to know who's the saver
and spender though because when i went
back to
my marriage matt and i i'm the spender
he's the saver if matt came to me and
said i want to buy a 5 000
gun i wouldn't even question that
purchase because he never
he never wants to spend money it's such
a big deal when he does that that's such
a
uh out of character thing it's such an
exciting thing like yeah what's this
purchase let's let's you know make sure
we've got the savings and so on but for
me i have to know my
temptation which is usually to reign it
in because i'm the spender so you know
you're part of the discussion too yes
you know it's a good thing to say out
loud
look um i'm this tight wad and so i'm
the no person the dream killer i don't
want to be that person
but you also don't want to be the
spender that runs us back into the hole
we just got out of
because a lot of those purchases were
you and when you bring this pattern to
me it scares me
yeah and that's a fair thing to say yeah
to know what your weak spots are
yeah and so um you know sharon and i
have had those discussions because i'm
the spender
and she would say you know when you're
doing this or acting this way it's
reminding me of back when we went
bankrupt yeah
and uh it's like it like opens up that
wound yeah
you know and so just have that
discussion just talk about it out loud
then you can walk through and come up
with plans to get some stuff
you know whether whether it's a couch a
gun a purse a trip i don't care or a
house
none all of those things are proper
there's not like you're an absolute
idiot for doing one of those
others it's not this is the stage that
you would do those things at but
only when you both feel good about it
and honestly rebecca you might be more
concerned about his
pattern of spending than you are this
actual purchase it might be bothering
that it's looking like it did before
like it did with sharon so good good
discussion thank you for calling in